in previous videos we had talked about
the 1896 supreme court case plessy
versus ferguson which is a good one to
know in general if you're studying
united states history and or united
states government but this is where we
got the principle of separate
separate
but
equal where the supreme court said in
1896 that it was okay to have
segregation it was okay to separate
folks on a racial basis as long as what
they got was equal this was the case
around whether it was unconstitutional
for an african american in louisiana to
have to sit in a separate rail car from
white passengers now as you can imagine
this idea of segregation and separate
but equal it was taken to justify racial
segregation in all walks of life
including in schools
and what you see here is a map of the
united states and it's colored in by the
degree of school segregation educational
segregation as we enter into the 1950s
and what you could see is in these red
states here which is for the most part
the southern states it required the
separation of races in the green states
you see here segregation was forbidden
and in the yellow and blue states it was
kind of in between the yellow states had
no legislation and in the blue states it
was limited it wasn't required and all
this comes to a head as we get into the
1950s in topeka
kansas you have a situation where the
naacp in coordination with 13 parents
try to register african-american
students into white schools in topeka
kansas the schools try to prevent them
and it eventually goes to the united
states supreme court in the case of
brown versus board of education of
topeka 1954. oliver brown was one of
those 13 parents trying to get his
daughter into an otherwise segregated
school and this is a seminal supreme
court case because here the supreme
court revisits segregation and
essentially overturns plessy versus
ferguson the supreme court in a
unanimous decision ruled
we conclude that in the field of public
education the doctrine of separate but
equal has no place
separate educational facilities are
inherently unequal
therefore we hold that the plaintiffs
and others similarly situated for whom
the actions have been brought are by
reason of the segregation complained of
deprived of the equal protection of the
laws guaranteed by the 14th amendment
and we cite the 14th amendment a lot in
these supreme court cases and it never
hurts to take another look at at least
an excerpt of the 14th amendment and
this is a focus on the equal protection
clause this is part of section 1 of the
14th amendment nor shall any state
deprive any person of life liberty or
property without due process of law and
then this is the equal protection clause
nor deny to any person within its
jurisdiction the equal protection of the
laws and this is a big deal because not
only does it say that hey segregation is
fundamentally unconstitutional what's
also interesting about this is that this
unanimous ruling by the united states
supreme court then sets off a whole
series of actions by politicians than
those states that you saw where
segregation was mandatory to try to go
around the supreme court's decision
and so it's a case of how other branches
of government
might try to limit supreme court powers
or try to ignore in some cases supreme
court powers
a good example of this was virginia
senator harry byrd in 1956 shortly after
the brown versus board of education
decision he issues this southern
manifesto where he gets a hundred
politicians in the south to essentially
sign on saying hey we are going to do
what we can legislatively to try to get
around the brown versus board of
education decision we are going to try
to ensure that that does not go into
effect in segregated states like
virginia and later that year in 1956 it
took the form of this massive resistance
movement where they had the stanley plan
named after the virginia governor in
which they started to pass laws to try
to make brown versus board of education
not take effect one of them for example
said that any school that actually
desegregated would not receive state
funds and it authorized the governor to
close those schools down and this
massive resistance continued and was
challenged in the courts all the way to
1959 where you actually have the first
integrated schools in the state of
virginia
another state level challenge to the
ruling by the supreme court happened in
1957
where the governor of arkansas
orville fabus tried to actively prevent
nine students nine african-american
students from attending little rock
central high school and so what you see
in this picture over here these are us
army troops sent by president eisenhower
to escort these nine students into
little rock central high school these
nine students are famously known as the
little rock nine and this is actually a
picture of governor orville fabus later
complaining about this intervention and
this continues on for some time
you fast forward to 1963.
this is alabama governor george wallace
physically using himself to block two
african-american students from
registering at the university of alabama
once again in this situation the
president had to take action this time
john f kennedy he federalized the
national guard and he made them force
governor wallace to step aside so that
those students could register at the
university of alabama
so the big picture here is that brown
versus board of education is a seminal
case in american history but it also
tells us how the legislative branch and
state governments might try to go around
decisions that they don't like sometimes
they might just ignore the decision
until they're forced to pay attention to
it or they might try to legislate their
way around it and have a fight in the
court system until they're forced to go
one way or the other